hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse Orion comm and in this video I'm
going to show you how to check the
tricep deep tendon reflex so let me show
you how it's done okay now we're going
to check the tricep deep tendon and it
is located on the back of the arm right
above the elbow and if you're just new
you're trying to find it what you can do
is just extend the arm out and you can
feel just right above the elbow that
deep tendon so what you're going to do
is you want this whole area to be
relaxed so we're going to help the
patient dangle their arm tell them to
let it go limp and this is going to
check c7 to c8 what we're going to do is
we're going to take the hammer and just
briskly hit on that deep tendon and what
you'll see is extension of the forearm
and a slight contraction of the tricep
so here we go and seeing that seam that
flex and that contract do it one more
time okay so that is how you check that
deep tendon reflex now check out my
other videos on how to check the other
for deep tendon reflexes and consider
subscribing to this YouTube channel